seasonal affect disorder is a form of
depression that affects millions of
people every year do you suffer from the
winter Blues well here to tell us more
about it is Leticia Morgan a licensed
clinical social worker from
Intermountain Healthcare the sponsors of
this segment welcome to the show and
thank you for talking to us about
something that I think a lot of people
suffer from what is seasonal affect
disorder so again it's a form of
depression and it usually occurs at the
end of fall and lasts throughout winter
so you'll start to see a change in about
March but it's when the the time changes
it gets a little darker so people are
inside a little bit more and it just
kind of affects our mood so if you think
of depression but think of it at the
same time each year now what are some of
the symptoms that people maybe should be
looking out for if if you're feeling
kind of down like you said what what
kind of things should we look out for so
increase sleep increase appetite for
carbs just kind of tiredness not really
wanting to engage kind of withdrawing
that's something that I mean I think a
lot of people can relate to I know I
feel that and like you said when the
time changes all of a sudden I'm just
tired all the time and yeah I want to
stay home and eat what kind of things
can we do to treat seasonal affect
disorder so getting outside sunlight is
going to be the most important thing
because it's getting dark faster so of
course saying you want to go to sleep
you want to get your nighttime routine
started so if you take a break at work
you go out and take a walk get fresh air
also talking to someone helps I mean
it's not a long-term thing but it's
someone that you can talk to about the
symptoms that you're experiencing that's
nice to know and if if you are looking
for that light at the end of the tunnel
you said maybe around March is when
things kind of change for people yeah so
right when time changes again and it's
lighter longer and then also it starts
to warm up so we're wanting to be
outside a little bit more now when you
say talk to someone who who's someone
they talk to their doctor do you look
for a therapist what do you what do you
suggest so you can talk to your doctor
and they can connect you to a therapist
like how we do it in a mountain there
are different sites and things that you
can also find therapists on but there's
amazing therapists here in the valley
that you can talk to if someone wants to
reach out to you and get help from
Intermountain Healthcare how do they do
that so they'll just need to talk to
their primary care provider and they'll
link them to us yeah this is uh
definitely something that a lot of
people are dealing with I told you right
before I said I think this is something
that I deal with on a daily basis thank
you so much for such a great information
are there also like supplements maybe
that people that you would recommend
that people could take well I don't want
to recommend but you know just talk to
your doctor and they can let you know
like if you need to increase certain
vitamins and things like that it's
always good because Health should be the
priority here and mental health is just
as important thank you so much Leticia
for all of your knowledge for more
information visit
intermountainhealthcare.org forward
slash Nevada Las Vegas now we'll be
right back